That is a flat out line ever we could just
ask the next schmuck who walks through Hey
sir hi hi I really don't care as long
as I get a good Cameo call my agent
Savvy I'm Stan Lee I've been writing stories
for the Young Generation for the past 30 years
during this time I think I've learned a
lot about what young people think more
importantly I think I've learned a lot about
what young people are we're going to try to
present a voice that somebody will listen to
The Voice is needed we hope it will be ours
they are ladies and gentlemen
one and only Mr Stan Lee
Stan was doing one of his panels and they
asked me to come up and just say hi to me
but I came up I shook his hand I think the
microphone caught it but I whispered in
his ear I said hey they just wanted me to come
here and shake your hand but while I'm up here
I want to say thank you you saved my life
because the light that I have today there's a
direct line to that first comic book to hear
well Stan's best creation was always Stan
as a creative figure is one thing stand
as a personality was able to somehow tap
into his own Larger than Life self-effacing and
self-aggrandizing at the same time personality as
I would describe it that PT Barnum aspect of him
it's just something he infused the group with and
it's something that the people who followed him or
have been able to kind of keep that energy going
I think Stan lee is going to be an icon what he
represents what he was able to accomplish he built
American mythology because stories are really what
stay with us those characters that he created when
he infused Marvel the brand with have always shown
through even if they have superpower they have
to be believable what they do has to be what any
normal person would do in those situations and the
idea that he championed all all kinds of different
voices all kinds of points of view and the concept
of diversity and equality and conversations about
you know social politics all these things he
had been doing for for years and now it's at the
Forefront of everything that we talk about I just
think he was just connected in that way and he was
connected to who his true audience was and who he
was really writing for he complimented that with
always being hopeful with his own first person
personality of being Stan my earliest memories
of Stan were reading those soap boxes you felt
like he was talking directly to you and no one
else what I didn't realize was that there was a
kid behind me at the candy store reading the same
thing feeling the exact same way his ideology was
very clear it was very black and white and white
good how to chill equally and that's a really
powerful impact to lean into the light as much
as you can even if there's Darkness all around
you in writing the soapboxes I used to just talk
to the readers anything that came to my mind just
to make the books not seem like something cold
and aloof and it's something you buy and you
throw away I wanted them to feel buying a Marvel
book was like visiting an old friend without that
we wouldn't be experiencing the success we had
today people like that creative Geniuses like
that you can't help but walk away learning lessons
they they have a way of delivering messages that
you know just resonate with those of us who
who have followed his work and followed the
characters he's created he made it feel intimate
and that anybody could belong to it we're really
lucky to have him really Define us because it's
really given us something to move forward with
Welcome back everyone Marvel has a bunch of big
movies and series coming up in 2023 and they just
announced a special Stan Lee documentary which
seems like something they should have done a long
time ago so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel I'll be doing videos
for all of it just like I do for the other big
Marvel movies and Disney plus episodes the first
real big one coming up in 2023 is Ant-Man the
Wasp quantumania with Kang the Conqueror that's
going to be the beginning of Marvel phase five
we'll get a new trailer for that really soon
the first big Marvel Disney plus Series in 2023
will be the secret Invasion episodes that starts
in March and it's going to set up a much larger
Marvel Phase 5 plot with the evil Scrolls that'll
culminate in Captain America 4 New World Order
in the Thunderbolts movie with a very dark rain
Vibe just in general it's part of the reason
why they recast the Thunderbolt Ross character
after William Hurt passed away with Harrison
Ford like why Harrison Ford would even bother
showing up in a Marvel movie they literally and
metaphorically have big plans Big Red Hulk plans
for Thunderbolt bras but they're also going to
make him the president of the United States by
the events of Captain America 4. thanks to what
happens during secret Invasion if you've read the
dark rain Arc in the comics and because of what
Val has been doing behind the scenes they kind
of teased that during her scenes in Black Panther
wakanda forever she's the new director of the CIA
and wields way more power and authority than she
did back during Falcon and Winter Soldier the Stan
Lee documentary is part of the cool documentary
content they started doing more of like bigger
versions of the Marvel assembled episodes that go
behind the scenes of all the Marvel movies in the
Disney plus series it'll cover his entire life how
he started out as this lowly writer for a small
publishing company that nobody really thought too
much about timely comics and helped turned it into
the PowerHouse that Marvel company you see today
there have actually been a couple Easter eggs for
the beginning of Marvel Comics like Way Way Back
in the early days in the She-Hulk series and again
during Loki season 2. we haven't got the Loki
season 2 episodes yet but I spotted some cool
references in Easter eggs in the background of
some of the footage for the episodes during the
She-Hulk episode so she winds up getting hired
by the law firm GLK and H the full name of the
law firm is Goodman Lieber kurtzberg and Holloway
the founding members of what became Marvel Martin
Goodman was the original owner of timely Comics
who hired a young Stanley Lieber Stan Lee's
original birth name he changed it along with
other comic book artist kurtzberg who's also
part of the title there which is the real name
of Jack Kirby named Jack kurtzberg the law firm
was already canonized by the comics and they
just turned it into a live-action MCU Easter
egg after the fact the other funny connection
to all of his famous Stan lee cameos is his very
first ever Cameo it was during the original
1970s Incredible Hulk TV series they later
parodied the intro from that 1970s Incredible
Hulk series during the She-Hulk finale but this
is the very first Stan Lee Cameo ever answer
the question maybe you must answer the question
the big Easter egg for the Loki season 2 was for
timely comics and Martin Goodman so during one of
the episodes it takes place in the 1970s London
they go to the premiere of the zaniac movie who
is a Marvel comic book character who's like an
actor who becomes the character that he's playing
it's like a movie within a movie kind of thing
and if you zoom in enhance on the movie poster
credits here for all the other actors names the
production crew members names the production
company is listed as a Goodman production that's a
huge Easter egg for the origin of the Marvel comic
book company itself originally the company was
owned by Martin Goodman who owned timely Comics
that was the original name of Marvel Comics he's
the one who hired a young Stan Lee Jack Kirby all
those classic era Marvel creatives that you know
then later the company changed his name a couple
times eventually changing it to Marvel Comics
they've used this type of Easter egg in Marvel
Productions before they used it during Moon night
too when they're revealing the true origin of the
Steven Grant Persona that he was a character
in a fictional movie called tomb Busters the
production company of that movie on the poster
was listed as timely Atlas Productions that was
another Easter egg for timely Comics but what
happened is is it started out as timely Comics
then in the 1950s they changed their name to Atlas
Comics then after that they changed their name to
Marvel Comics at the premiere they have Easter
eggs for a bunch of different real movies and
fake in Universe movies just because that's kind
of a thing within Marvel Now is having movies
within movies like you can see the kingo's first
movie is airing at this theater my very favorite
Stan lee Cameo scene is actually from the 90s
Spider-Man the Animated Series where he meets
a real version of Stan Lee going to the Marvel
Comics offices in the show Madam Webb who also
was a big character during the series and helped
make that Cameo possible also is played by his
real-life wife Joan who he references during his
Cameo scene like who was that woman she actually
did finally get a live action Cameo with him
during X-Men apocalypse everyone let me know
what your favorite Stan Lee Cameo scene is in
the comments below but there'll be a bunch more
Marvel trailers coming really soon like another
major secret Invasion trailer early this year
there's supposed to be another brand new Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania trailer after New Year's
Eve so whenever they wind up releasing of course
they'll do videos for it there was another really
cool Captain America 4 X-Men Wolverine Weapon X
announcement a little while ago I'll try to do a
video for that later today so that video should be
up pretty soon they just released another new one
you can click here to watch that and click here
for my new Loki season 2 trailer video in Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!